so picture this it was a beautiful
Tuesday Morning in
2018 I've just wrapped up the final test
of a shiny app which I'm convinced to be
the game changer our team needs my
coffee even tastes like
success but reality check F fast forward
a month the app I thought was good had
zero
visits now I was no rook in Shen of
development back then I've already built
and launched half dozen of those here's
a Twist the popularity did not grow as I
add more feny wids of
functions one day while watching Silicon
Valley a TV show about the ups and downs
of a startup it hit me that building and
launching a shiny app is just like
starting a company where the app is the
product it is important but also just
one piece of the whole puzzle there are
other things to consider in the whole
process in the next 16 minutes I will
walk through all the other similarities
between the two and Trace back in my map
they help turn my apps from zero usage
to now
handling 160,000 requests in the last
few
years now similar to a startup a shiny
app also starts from idea
so in the startup world there's a saying
there's a quote that about why to start
a company that
goes don't build a startup for the sake
of building a startup trying to get
people more focused on the problem it
tries to solve and which can be
perfectly applied to shiny apps to build
a shiny app we need to First find out of
the problem well this is probably easy
to say but for me I came up with
absolutely nothing for the first few
months after learning about sh chiny so
where can we look for these ideas here
are the directions I found now think
about all of these startups many of
those ideas would fall under the
following three categories uh things
that everyone can use uh things that
would replace repeated work processes
and things that were solve challenges in
a few organizations or Industries but
now even with these directions they're
still hard to come up
with but luckily we are trying to
implement a shiny app at a workplace
which allows us to add one condition in
the end now for shiny apps looking for
things that everyone can use in the
company is less difficult and repeated
work processes in a department are
probably common to spot and pain points
for a specific team are much easier to
identify now these directions May
provide you a more targeted view when
you were trying to find the
problem now once you find the initial
idea it does not mean just go ahead and
do it we need still need to validate
them so for startups they would do
market research to trying to measure the
need and talk to Consumers to understand
the problem if they don't do that I'm
pretty sure we would all have a glow
in-the-dark sunglasses now so for shiny
apps to make sure there is a real need
we can do our own market research by for
example measuring the amount of efforts
the shiny app could safe to trying to
quantify the impact and we can also talk
to the potential users in this case our
colleagues to understand the problem and
how may the new solution affect the
workflow now if you have to a while
there's still no idea comes to mind we
can still see what are the ideas we can
copy after all not all startups were
built on or or ideas to save myself from
unnecessary lawsuits I'm not going to
name any names but it is totally fine
from to learn from cases that work for
other companies and organizations and
apply it to yours so with that I've
listed a few examples on my blog which
I'm going to share in the end that may
help you customize a solution for your
organization to dive deeper into just
one example often times when
stakeholders wants to make let's just
say data informed decisions they would
reach out to the data teams who then
runs a set of secal code to extract from
databases compile the results and share
back with the
stakeholders now when those secq code
are similar or easy to modify it is
possible for us to save some efforts to
do that we can create a shiny app that
allows stakeholders to directly interact
with databases without having to go
through the data teams we can even make
it possible to email the results so that
nobody has to wait for the job to
complete and make it possible to handle
multiple request at the same time so
overall to find the ideas for both
startups and shiny apps there are three
directions we can think about but we
have a much smaller scope for shiny
apps and before any development work we
need to validate the idea by possibly
quantify the impact and talk to the
users lastly if there's no ideas comes
to mind we can see what are the ideas we
can
copy and now after confirming the
idea startups will need financial
support so your shiny apps so in that
imp patient for Investments there was
another saying in the start world that
goes don't pitch the product pitch the
business trying to get people focused on
pitching the broader business
opportunities which can also apply to
shiny
apps and when asking resources for shiny
app development we need to focus on Less
on the shiny app features and more on
the impact and you may already have the
impact while doing the stage of
validating your ideas so we just need to
find the right group P people to talk to
so for startups there are a few the
first one is the incubators so this is
where the incubator founder uh who's
more experienced more resourceful will
guide you as you build your product and
more often they will work together with
you as with the investors when more
Investments are needed this could be a
common case for shiny app where you are
still you uh the incubated founder in
this case would be your manager who
would provide you the initial
Investments of time and resources and
instead of presenting together with the
investors you guys would present
together with the stakeholders when more
Investments are needed
now for startups that did not with work
with incubators but still need
Investments you will sometimes see them
on Pitch contest like uh Shark Tank
where they are directly pitching in
front of the
investors for us the idea is to look for
internal opportunities like hackathon or
innovation activities where you can
directly bring your ideas forward in
front of the
stakeholders now even if the previous
two are not an option you can still uh
try the last option where um to get the
funding via crowd opt crowdfunding
option like Kickstarter where you're
directly pitching from the users
similarly for shiny apps we can do the
same by directly connecting with the
users in this case your colleagues to
get them to promote your app and ask for
the resources from their
supervisor one person may not provide
enough help multiple may you get the
idea now overall to find the Investments
while startups would work with
incubators we would work with our
supervisors to get the initial
Investments and when start startups
would get on Pitch contacts like Shark
Tank we can look for internal
opportunities uh like hackathon or
innovation activities to bring your
ideas forward in front of the
stakeholders lastly even if the previous
thre on option you can still try the
crowdfunding option like Kickstarter to
directly pitch resources from the
users now once your Investments are
secured time to develop product
now when it comes to shiny a development
there's so many great resources so I'm
going to keep on this one very brief but
when it comes to developing the product
there is another quote in the startup
world that goes it is not about building
the best product but building the right
one trying to get people focused on just
the necessary
features and which also applies to the
shiny app because the one thing that
both startups and shiny apps need to
steer away from is to be
overdeveloped to do that while startups
would try to stick with the core
features for shiny apps we need to
minimize all the nights to have widgets
which can be really hard to do because I
know for me and so for some of the other
sheny have the opers coming up the
possible features to add to the app is
almost like n-j reaction you just can't
help it for example when there is state
or Province data I would immediately
think about possibly adding a
interactive cor PL map and when there is
a plain uh text file export needed I
instantly think about possibly adding a
download button which will allow users
to download the HTML document that would
host the plas and tables which often
ended with functionality that wasn't
utilized as well as overwhelmed
users and now even if we can keep
ourselves in check it is still possible
that new ideas may come up throughout
the development now for for startups
while they will need to avoid scope
Creek through from uh all areas for
shiny apps we will need to manage all
the new feature requests coming from
users or
stakeholders now often times it is going
to be more than just the amount of
efforts it takes to make the feature
possible but whether if it is a
necessary one because almost no one
would mind waiting for a few extra days
to get a Swiss army knife when all they
needed is a
toothpick now after the product is built
or the shiny app is built time to take
off the shiny at aler hat and try to
focus on getting users after all you
can't expect the users to commentate
automatically as another saying also in
the startup World goes build it and they
will come only happens in the movies so
what are the things that startup would
try to do to get more customers well for
that I'll probably need to take the
whole rest of the afternoon to talk
about it but luckily I don't have the
slice so let me just mention a few
examples there one of the first things
the S tried to do is to market the
product by bringing a strong brand
identity which is something that we can
do as well for the shiny a development
to try to bring our own
personality for example you may know
some of these as the 80s action movies
but what you do not know is that they
are also the names of the app that I
built and launch at
work uh for the recer these shiny app
functionalities has nothing to do with
the movie content but the truth is that
no one is going to remember the app name
if I try to name it solely based on what
it really does but combined with my
personal interest and the weak
connection I can find between the
business goals as well as the app name I
was able to create a fun and popular
reference among users and these are the
apps that help solve 160,000 requests in
the last few
years the other thing that startups have
try to do is to try to make their
product more accessible V let to say
enhancing the search engine results
luckily we don't have to do that for an
internal shiny app but we can certainly
try to make things more accessible by
building a landing page with C name so
imagine these are the list of shin that
you have at your workplace along with
the simulated links now if your users
are not super organized with with web
links or a super user of bookmarking it
is almost a certainty that someone will
need to dig around the communication
will ask you about the links of their
shiny app or the shiny app that you
build so instead of asking my users to
do that I've set up a c name which in
this case is an alias to an internal web
address and build a landing page that
would host the directory for all the
shiny apps that I buil now for the users
instead of having to remember all of
these links above all they need to
remember now is one word the c name put
it into the internal web browser which
will take them to the landing page that
will host all of these applications and
based on the previous movie reference I
had you can probably guess what that c
name might be for my landing page now
the last thing the startups would want
to do is to enable the product content
sharing via what of month for shiny apps
we can achieve similar Effects by
allowing the users to share the
following things for example the work
results and then this is where we can
easily enable by having an emailing
option or download button of the results
from the shiny app work pro work
progress can also be shared if we have a
building functionality for the users to
see the sessions that they have ever
used and what are the before and after
impact and lastly no one has ever said
that shiny apps couldn't be fun we have
created customized messages that will
pop up randomly while a user is waiting
for a job to
complete now for the record phyas is a
real coworker and a user of the
app now overall to reach more customers
while startups would Market the product
via a strong brand identity we can do
the same by bring our own personality
starting with a name when startups would
make their product accessible via
various ways and then we can build a
landing page with C name to make our
shining app more
accessible lastly Word of Mouth can be a
powerful marketing tool and we can
enable that by creating things like work
results work progress and customize
messages for the users to
share now after that there's one more
thing operations so like startups shiny
apps is not something that's one and
done it is something that will require a
continuous development
and for both startups and shiny apps the
one thing that they need to take care of
are its customers so while you can see
that the startups they would spend a lot
of efforts to trying to ensure there is
a smooth customer own boarding
experience for shiny apps we need to
make sure our apps are still
userfriendly
or providing a smooth experience for the
new users by placing resources like a
detailed read me or a u uh recording
instructions
so while startups would also care about
the customer success we will need to
think about if we are providing the ways
to gather feedback to provide what the
user need one of the other things that
the startups would need to take care of
are the communication with their
investors and if you think about all of
these quarterly Financial calls almost
every single one of them would follow
the following structure that would start
with a financial performance review for
the last quarter and to talk about any
operational highlights or wins or
challenges and ended with guidance or
outlook for shiny apps it is also very
important for us to connect with our
stakeholders to let them know what's
going on with the Investments and
similarly we can follow the structure
that starts with the app usage and
impact then we talk about any wins or
challenges along the way and end it with
what to expect
next overall while startups will support
the customer own boarding and success we
need to make sure we are engaging both
new and existing
users when companies would do at least a
quarterly Financial call with the
investors we need to make sure we're
considering meeting regularly with the
stakeholders to let them know that their
Investments are still
healthy now you can probably see that
building and launching a shiny app is
just like starting a company where we
will all start from an idea and it would
need to validate the idea before any
development when we need resources we
need to reach out to the managers
stakeholders or users for help and when
it comes to the product development or
the app development knowing that there
are so many great resources out there we
still need to just try to keep only the
necessary features and manage any new
request that comes along the way
building the app is not enough we need
to market the product by giving it a
brand identity starting with a name make
it more accessible with C name as well
as a landing page and create sharable
information for the
users lastly shiny apps is not something
that's well and done it is something
that will require a continuous effort
while we are making sure we're engaging
with both new and existing users let's
make sure also plan out the connection
with the stakeholders to talk about
what's happened what's new and what's
next overall the whole journey is the
shiny app now if you forgot everything
we just talked about or if you just
walked in remember this whenever you
feel lost in a shiny app Journey just
think about what the startup direction
would be and you will be just fine thank
you all right thank you tiger we've got
time for a couple of questions you can
find those in the slido so first up what
are your recommend commendations for
hosting shiny and making apps available
oh uh POS it
connect all right next question uh how
do you how do you how do you evaluate
the success of an app Beyond requests or
user numbers Beyond request and what
user numbers oh yeah so so let's just
say the user num is and all that is uh
it's almost like one of the generical
ways right it's almost like you can
apply to everywhere but but think about
a shiny app that would be able to share
some of the business insights those are
the ones maybe is less frequently asked
questions that you getting the answer
but it is still possible that these will
fund and then EMP power all of these
much more bigger business decisions that
may impact some of the much bigger
budgets there so I would say for
different organizations you would have
probably have different ways of
evaluating that but let's not just limit
to the amount of users or the amount of
request to handles okay fantastic thank
you again tiger right
[Applause]
thanks